which of these items would you feel
comfortable putting in the recycling box
they've got toothpaste coffee cup and a
pizza box
you think pizza box yeah what do you do
Madam yeah pizza box none of these are
allowed to be recycled if it's got
grease stains on it is that surprising
oh
I would just make it into an airplane
that's one way of recycling out of these
items then got toothpaste coffee cup
pizza box
which of these would you put in the
recycling I would um yeah definitely
with that question mark with that and no
to that would it surprise you that if
the pizza box had grease stains on it
you wouldn't be able to recycle it that
does surprise me gosh yeah wow this one
would it surprise you that if it's got
grease stains on it you can't recycle it
all right that's surprising because I
always throw in the bin though I don't
know I mean I would just throw it all in
the recyclable well now when I go home
I'm gonna think should I or shouldn't I
so now you've given me a problem I'm
sorry